[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date a dit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
jacques baud ancien membre des services
de renseignement suisses vous avez été
le chef d'une cellule spéciale de
renseignements sur le terrorisme vous
avez le grade de colonel vous avez
travaillé pour les nations unies a le
temps vous avez dirigé la lutte contre
la prolifération des armes légères vous
êtes l'auteur de nombreux livres sur le
renseignement est sûre la guerre
contrôle de terroristes aujourd'hui vous
publié chez max milo gouverné par les
fake news un livre explosif comme on va
le voir de 400 pages où vous revenez sur
30 ans de conflits internationaux pour y
traquer les fêtes news qui ont pu être
utilisés par les pays occidentaux pour
motiver leurs alliés les médias où
l'opinion publique mais on commence
comme d'habitude par notre époque qu'est
ce qui la caractérise ce qui caractérise
ce début du 21ème siècle
voici votre réponse en images jacques
baud l'image la voici alors où c'était
et pourquoi avez vous choisi là c'est
une image de ce un pays où j'ai été que
j'ai dont j'ai gardé un excellent
souvenir un pays dit il mais beaucoup de
respect à un pays où quand dignité dans
la population et que j'ai beaucoup aimée
somalie hassan ali et il ya cette image
de tron est en fait et ernie ball ou
plus qu'on imagine la politique et la
sécurité dans nos pays puisque et ses
drôles de sons ces drones qui
encouragent en définitive les
terroristes à venir exercer chez nous
leurs entre guillemets taton pourquoi
parce qu'ils estiment que par les drones
au fond nous faisons la même chose chez
eux que ce qu'il pourrait faire chez
nous en posant des bombes ou en
mitraillant les gens dans les rues
alors en vérité il de faire pression sur
les populations occidentales pour que
ces populations demandent à leur pays de
cesser de bombarder et c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé en france il y a cinq
quand en dents dans l'hyper cacher et à
charlie hebdo
c'est ce qui s'est passé un peu partout
en europe c'est en fait cette manière de
faire la guerre que nous avons à
l'encontre d'ailleurs du droit
international et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
la sole le seul outil que ces théories
sont trouvés bons ou mauvais c'est
d'essayer d'influencer à leur tour dans
le sens inverse les opinions
occidentales
les sages c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
eux qui le disent ils ont un diplôme
dans leurs écrits on le trouve ça dans
leur publication
mais aussi dans les vidéos qui ont été
diffusés partiellement en occident dont
on a d'ailleurs toujours enlever ce
passage dans les vidéos qu'on a montré
on a montré les horreurs ne l'a pas
montré le message des terroristes et où
il explique pourquoi il frappe chez mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec une domination
mondiale une guerre sainte contre
l'occident ou une domination mondiale
ça c'est une scène on entre déjà là dans
le domaine des fausses vérités où on
essaye en fait d'esquiver la
responsabilité occidental dans cette
réaction par le terrorisme n'est rien
d'autre qu'une réaction à des actions
occidentales et bien commençons
[Musique]
jacques baud votre livre gelé dans la
main il fait 400 pages je disais tout à
l'heure qu'il était explosif on va s'en
apercevoir en en parlant mais avant même
d'en parler qu'est ce qui nous prouve
que vous vous même vous ne vous faites
pas de la désinformation après tout vous
êtes un homme du renseignement
peut-être que vous faites exactement la
même chose que ce que vous reprochez aux
pays occidentaux
qu'est ce qui nous prouve que vous
n'êtes pas un conspirationniste qui va
glaner des renseignements sur des
sources improbable qu'est ce qui nous
prouve que vous n'êtes pas payé par
vladimir poutine comme je le suis moi
par exemple
et qu'est ce qui nous prouve que nous
vous ne faites pas partie de la gérance
russe on va probablement vous le
reprocher à ceux qui liront ce livre se
diront oh la la c'est de l'ingérence
russe alors qu'est ce que vous répondez
à toutes ces accusations qu'on n'a pas
encore porté mais comportera forcément
un jour alors si j'ai anticipé
maintenant ces accusations en fait
toutes les sources que j'utilise sont
des sources que j'ai vérifié et qui sont
réputés factuel c'est à dire des sources
qui se base sur les faits et j'ai les
cartes et d'autorité toutes les sources
qui pourraient être soupçonnées ou qui
sont des sources à tendance
conspirationnistes ou même de tendances
politiques trop écartées parce
qu'effectivement on trouve soit à gauche
soit à droite on trouve que toutes les
opinions sur nous et j'ai écarté un peu
de tout les toutes les sources qui
pourrait être sujette à caution
par ailleurs j'ai mis l'accent sur les
publications officielles
c'est à dire que beaucoup d'informations
qui nous sont données par la presse
américaine occidental en général elle
est souvent contredites par des rapports
officiels des rapports de services de
renseignement et c'est de ces lames à
base de travail pour dénoncer les faits
que news j'ai également également écarté
des sites que je considère comme un
honnête mais qui sont en occident pour
différentes raisons
suspecté d'être orientés à 20h dans un
pays où contre d'autres pays
et ça que je les écarter d'emblée non
pas parce que ces sites sont de mauvaise
qualité bien au contraire mais parce que
on pourrait effectivement dire qu'ils
disent mobilisés
alors on reste sur une informe et
travailler exactement comme officier de
renseignement devrait faire c'est à dire
sur de l'information et factuelle qui
est vérifiable qui est accessible toute
information qui hélas est vérifiée et
est accessible partout
c'est pour ça qu'il ya autant d'ailleurs
de le note de bas de page en effet il y
en a beaucoup
ce que vous appelez les faits que news
le mot figure dans le titre gouverné par
les fakes news on peut le traduire aussi
vous ne vous en privez pas dans le livre
par la notion de fausses vérités
il ya comme ça des vérités qui
deviennent établi mais qui sont en
réalité des fausses vérités
on se souvient et c'est sans doute la
plus célèbre des armes de destruction
massive de saddam hussein c'est ce qui
avait servi aux américains on voit
colline powell derrière moi aux nations
unies coline powell représentaient les
états unis mais les états unis comme la
grande bretagne se sont servis de ces
soi-disant d'armes de destruction
massive pour justifier l'invasion en
irak
c'est un stack cas d'école pour vous et
à l'époque
est ce que ça vous a paru comme vous
quand vous les entendez parler des armes
de destruction massive
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous
alerte vous en tant qu'homme du
renseignement habitué à analyser ce
genre de de propagande
alors d'abord je peux vous et quelques
mois avant la prestation de monsieur que
web powell au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies j'avais moi même fait un
rapport très circonstancié sur la
question des armes de destruction
massive en irak
puisque j'étais c'est un sujet que
jackie était tombé dans mon escarcelle
entre guillemets lorsque je travaillais
aux affaires étrangères j'ai fait un
rapport circonstancié qui affirmait
qu'il n'y avait pas d'armes de
destruction massive et que les
américains nous mener en bateau
mon rapport a été poliment écarté il ce
prétexte que les américains était notre
principal partenaire et que la suisse
n'a ciel n'allait certainement pas
s'engager contre l'avis des américains
donc on le savait très bien c'est un cas
d'école c'est un cas un peu extrême
aussi parce que c'est un cas où tout le
monde savait en réalité que les
américains mentait mais que tout le
monde a marché dans le mensonge parce
que finalement ça arrange et un peu tout
le monde de d'entrer dans la combine si
j'ose dire pardon je vous attends donc
on prend bien dans votre livre qu'à
chaque fois l'enjeu c'est souvent de
présenter l'adversaire comme un monstre
ou en tout cas quelqu'un de pire que
nous c'est à dire que oui bien dedans
d'entrer en guerre d'avoir un pays ça
n'est pas bien on le sait mais là ça
vaut vraiment la peine parce que celui
là il est horrible
voilà c'est exactement
et l effet un peu pervers de fausses
vérités c'est à dire sur la base
d'informations est partenaire très
partiels ont créé une vérité une ce
qu'on appelle techniquement une aisance
cognitives sur le fait que le poutine
est un indicateur que bachir al assad
est un monstre
omar el bachir est un génocidaire et c
est ça devient ça entre dans le discours
habituel le discours officiel le
discours standards qu'on trouve dans les
médias et finalement ça n'étonne plus
personne n'est plus personne ne se pose
des questions sur des chiffres comme
200000 ou quatre cent mille morts au
darfour
et alors que personne n'a vérifié ces
givry et je suis bien placé pour savoir
parce que moi même à la tête de du
renseignement ou au soudan pendant deux
ans j'ai je me suis attaché à côté c'est
mort et on n'est jamais arrivé à 200
milles
on est arrivé au maximum à 2500 morts
donc on a créé pour différentes raisons
politiques surtout géostratégique aussi
on a créé effectivement une sorte de
fausse réalité qui facilite entre
guillemets comme vous l'avez dit des
prises de décisions qui sont à
l'encontre en fait du droit
international se justifie de cette
manière alors vous avez donné l'exemple
de omar el bachir au darfour pag 300
mille pages est possible de 300000 morts
d'après vous mais 2500 au mieux au
maximum sur kadhafi par exemple kadhafi
pour vous c'est quoi la fausse vérité ou
du moin la fé news la désinformation qui
a été pratiquée pour noircir
kadhafi était un dictateur vous le dit
évidemment dans ce livre mais pas
forcément celui qu'on a décrit quand on
a voulu renverser sa mère quand on a
voulu le renverser il a fallu justifier
une intervention qui était contraire au
droit international
donc on a on a créé de toutes pièces un
événement qui était contraire au droit
international pour justifier
l'intervention au nom de la
responsabilité de protéger qui est qui
et qui est défini par un par les nations
unies et ça a été le massacre de
benghazi que qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
dans beaucoup de d'articles aujourd'hui
alors qu'on sait et qu'on savait à
l'époque qu'il n'avait jamais eu lieu on
a des rapports des services de vente
m'en tiens à la même époque qui précise
qu'il n'y a jamais eu ce massacre
mais il a servi de prétexte et il reste
aujourd'hui inscrits dans les dents dans
l'immédiat d'une manière générale
manière indélébile et il continue d'une
certaine manière à excuser
l'intervention occidentale et bien
d'autres bachar el-assad par exemple en
quoi est ce qu'on a
bachar el-assad dont des armes chimiques
les massacres de homs et qui aujourd'hui
dans même à l'époque des massacres de
homs donc en 2011
les services de renseignements allemands
avaient établi qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
massacre causés par les deux de bachir
al assad dans la suite ça a été
évidemment les attaques chimiques qui
ont la vie dure mais qui ne sont qu ils
ne sont certainement pas le fait de
bachir el assad d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président obama
n'a pas n'est pas intervenue en août
2013 et sao le sait très bien des gens
le savez à l'époque ce sont les services
de renseignement aux militaires
américains qui ont déconseillé à obama
d'intervenir parce que tous les éléments
qu'ils avaient à ce moment là et kenzo
depuis aussi permettait d'indiquer
indiqué que c'était en fait les rebelles
qui avaient utilisé les armes
ces armes de destruction massive et donc
il ya trois événements majeurs sur les
armes de destruction massive ya celui de
de la goutte à près de hama ce en 2013
il y a une incidence and shame en 2016
et puis le 2010 est maintenant et puis
l'événement de 2018
à douma et là on sait que dans les trois
cas il n'y a pas eu le d'engagement des
armes d'armes par l'armée de syrienne en
revanche il ya eu dans le premier cas un
engagement d'aucun lag août à un
engagement par les rebelles dans le
deuxième cas on était à khan cheikhoune
on est très vraisemblablement dans le
cas d'un j'allais dire d'un accident
quelque sorte c'est à dire que les armes
chimiques à des médias pas eu d'armes
chimiques engagé mais des toxiques
chimiques qui ont été libérés par un
bombardement ciblé fait par les syriens
mais il n'y avait pas d'armes chimiques
engagé et puis dans le cas de douma 18
qui a déclenché ce tir conjointe de la
fin s'il frappe conjointe de la france
de la grande-bretagne et des etats-unis
en avril 2018 qui en fait il n'y a rien
du tout il ya simplement eu un
bombardement normal c'est j'ose dire
d'artillerie et puis les effets les
rebelles ont habilement utilisé les
effets les poussières enfin que tous les
effets ce de cette décision barre de man
pour faire croire qu'ils avaient eu un
engagement chimiques mais en fait
aujourd'hui on est il ya eu nombreux
d'ailleurs lanceur d' alerte au sein de
l'organisation des interdictions pour
les armes si des armes chimiques qui ont
confirmé que les rapports occidentaux
ont été falsifiés et en quelque sorte
pour pour justifier des frappes qui
d'ailleurs ont été lancés avant que les
experts des nations unies se rendre sur
place
donc on a on a effectivement créé on a
vraiment créer des fausses vérités pour
justifier les accusations des
engagements illégaux alors et vladimir
poutine parce que là on veut pas envahir
la russie et pourtant sur la russie
d'aujourd'hui ont dit bien pire que ce
que l'on disait du temps où l'urss était
communiste et occuper la moitié de
l'europe à l'époque
en france on n'était pas
particulièrement anti russe ni même anti
soviétique mais alors là c'est terrible
alors comment l'expliquez vous tout
d'abord moi j'ai quand il ya eu les
événements d'ukraine parce que c'est là
que les feux d'artifices déclenchés en
quelque sorte je travaille à l'otan et
je me suis aperçu qu on avait là une
mentalité encore qui datait de 30 en
quelque sorte en rester au niveau de la
guerre froide au niveau atp est dans
tous les cas et à bien des égards on est
resté là dessus en général c'est à dire
que on a notre image de la russie reste
celle de l'union soviétique d'une
certaine manière on sait qu'il ya eu des
changements mais on se plaît à conserver
cette cette image de l'union soviétique
alors pourquoi en réalité je pense que
la faire à commencer dès la fin de la
guerre froide où les occidentaux et
surtout les américains ont constaté que
la fin de la guerre froide était
finalement l'arrêt de mort de leur
industrie de l'armement de des dents
potentiel militaire qui est touché ce
qui est considéré comme étant un élément
fondamental de leur politique étrangère
et même d'ailleurs de leurs économies
puisque c'est finalement leur économique
d'essence qui a mieux survécu au fil des
années alors que d'autres industries
comme l'automobile l'industrie navale
etc vont péricliter
donc pour eux vraiment un enjeu de
préservation de l'eau de leurs capacités
et mais pour préserver cette capacité il
faut un ennemi et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la russie reste un peu
cet ennemi qui permet de justifier
d'ailleurs je peux moi-même en suisse
d'ailleurs les rapports de de sécurité
qui sont publiés chaque année continue à
voir la russie comme étant une menace
potentielle
même si c'est dit dans des termes plus y
quand même mais ça ça reste un peu
l'idée parce que il faut justifier
l'existence de moyens militaires de
l'acquisition des programmes d'armement
qui sont vraiment coûteux et ça c'est
tout merci de vous interrompre un génome
et des anti poutine ou des anti russe
vous dirai oui mais attendez ils ont
quand même bien cherché en crimée en
ukraine aujourd'hui en biélorussie où
avec la ferme la vanille ou dont on est
quand même à peu près certain
aujourd'hui certains en tout cas qu'il a
été empoisonné
alors je reviendrai sur un à ramener
mais on va prendre dans l'ordre et tout
d'abord concernant la d'ukraine
l'ukraine
on a un conflit et qui est un conflit
vraiment intérieur qui est issu d'une
des législations adoptées par la
nouvelle junte en ukraine sur les
langues etc c'est une âme en effet de
boule de neige qui s'est créé autour de
cette question d'aider longue
la crimée c'est un sujet un peu
particulier parce que contrairement
d'ailleurs assauts donc on écoute on
entend sur la crimée personne ne vous
dit que la crimée est en fait le premier
territoire de l'union soviétique et le
sound ailleurs avoir fait un référendum
d'autonomie et avoir été déclarée
autonome avant même l'indépendance de la
de l'ukraine et c'est après
l'indépendance de l'ukraine l'ukraine
n'a jamais honoré 7
cet engagement de l'urss de respecter ce
référendum qui a eu lieu en janvier 1991
et en réalité les ukrainiens n'ont fait
que le pardon les crimes et un nom n'ont
fait que durant 25 ans n'ont fait
qu'essayer d'avoir l'application de ceux
de ce droit qu'ils avaient et ils ont
trouvé l'occasion en 2014
et là les conditions de l'annexion sont
probablement discutable au niveau
international mais la légitimité de
l'indépendance de l'ukraine et la
décision de l'ukraine à vouloir
rejoindre la russie était n'est pas du
tout illégitime en réalité mais dont la
lie de désir de la crimée de rejoindre
la russie
oui de la crimée pas de l'ukraine
il est moins donc on a on a on a cessé
cet aspect nac qui n'est jamais évoquée
en occident donc les accusations qu'on a
contre la russie contre dans cette
affaire traînait n est assez discutable
en soi deuxièmement concert coup quand
on vient sur des affaires comme script à
louer ou navalni on reste quand même un
peu perplexe la manière dont ces
affaires arrivent d'abord elle arrive à
des moments très particuliers
elles ne sont la sphère navalni qui est
toute récente
on n'a pas un coup de pouce est rien le
fait qu'il aurait été qu'ils auraient
été empoisonnés
or on n'a pas d'histoire
d'empoisonnement de la part d'eads et
des services secrets eurus contrairement
à ce qu'on dit ou six émissions de radio
et de télévision en ce moment on énumère
tous les cas d'empoisonnement par les
services secrets russes justement le dos
à la tradition le seul vraiment avéré ça
a été l'assassinât de stepan bandera
en 1959 sauf erreur par les par les
services du comment du kgb mais sinon à
part ça même markov a été assassiné par
les services et les services bulgares
qu'entre aux autres est d'ailleurs le
même le cas de markov
cette affaire du parapluie bulgare qui a
été évoqué par tous elle n'est pas
démontré on ne sait même pas si ce
parapluie a tout simplement même exister
en réalité personne de la retrouver ce
sont simplement les dires d'un ancien
agent du kgb qui aurait affirmé que
probablement il aurait existé mais en
fait on n'en sait rien et concernant les
autres cas d'empoisonnement la sphère
skripal
eh bien elle est restée un peu suspendue
dans les nab
on ne sait pas du tout quelle est le fin
mot de l'histoire
en réalité tout porte à croire qu'on est
parti plus tôt d'une intoxication
alimentaire
car toutes les toutes les analyses qui
ont été faites par la suite n'ont jamais
démontré que la russie était impliqué on
a dans le meilleur des cas et si des
poisons j'allais dire des toxiques de
combat comme l'affirmait les les anglais
les britanniques avaient été utilisés on
ne sait même pas s'ils sont originaires
de russie
et ça tout à fait officiellement le
rapport le laboratoire de porto d'âne
aux etats-unis au royaume-uni pardon n'a
jamais pu confirmer que ce toxique
venait de la boîte de laboratoire russe
on sait que d'autres pays occidentaux
ont synthétisé 7,7 même toxines quand
inscrits par navalni on sait qu'il s'est
attaqué à la mafia on sait qu'il s'est
attaqué à des gens corrompus qu'ils
n'aiment que son ennemi n'est pas
nécessairement d'ailleurs l'état russe
même si le
c'est ce que ses ses coreligionnaires
prétendent en réalité il faut bien
comprendre que navalni qu'on présente en
occident comme étant l'opposant majeur à
comptines ne représente qu'un infime
pourcentage je parle équivalent au franc
ce serait peut-être l'upm de françois
asselineau en termes de quantité d'eau
d'importance donc on est sur quelque
chose de très petit par ailleurs navalni
dirige tout au plus une dirige en il est
à la tête d'un peu d'une constellation
de mouvements d'opposition dont les
rivalités sont connues et on pourrait
même imaginer que quelqu'un de son
entourage et tenté de l'empoisonner
mais ça pourrait tout aussi bien être
les personnes auxquelles ils s'attaquent
régulièrement en russie même et que là
je veux dire des des criminels ou des
gens qui sont notoirement corrompu
d'ailleurs les l'expérience ou plutôt
d'histoire montre que l'utilisation de
poisons en russie dans l'histoire
récente est plutôt la sphère de la mafia
que de l'état russe
en réalité et d'ailleurs on ne voit pas
très bien on ne voit pas très bien
pourquoi la russie se lancerait dans un
an dans une opération de ce genre là
alors que là n'est pas en reste encore
un petit peu comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure suspendu et il reste encore très
populaire en occident
ça n'a aucun sens en fait aucun sens
politique on fait une pause jacques baud
se retrouve juste après on continue de
parler de de gouverner par les fêtes
news votre nouveau livre
[Musique]
on continue cette émission avec jacques
baud un ancien membre des services de
renseignement suisses qui publie
gouverné par les faits que news chez max
milo un livre de 400 pages où sont
dénoncées les les fausses vérités
installé par les occidentaux pour
justifier des guerres des tentatives de
déstabilisation ou tout simplement des
campagnes de d2 diabolisation alors sur
sur l'iran par exemple parce que l'iran
celle axe du mal c'est le pays le plus
dangereux du monde
alors pour vous c'est quoi là la grosse
houle est fausse vérité qu'on a installé
sur l'iran depuis maintenant bas depuis
alors disons que la plus grosse c'est
sans doute au fait y en a deux à vrai
dire la première dans le dense et
d'affirmer que l'iran est le plus grand
promoteur du terrorisme international
c'est une accusation qui a été affirmé
par poweo et et donald trump
alors qu'on sait que le problème du
terrorisme international aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas le terroriste chiite mais
c'est le terrorisme islamiste sunnite
donc on voit pas très bien quel pourrait
être le rôle de l'iran là dedans et le
deuxième qui est sans doute plus
important du haut niveau régional c'est
l'accusation selon laquelle l'iran
entraide se doter d'une arme nucléaire
eux qui est d'ailleurs et ironiquement
c'est une accusation qui était alors
dans un sens assez amusante puisque on
sait que durant les années du chat c'est
israël qui avait proposé de doter l'iran
d'armes nucléaires à retrouver les
documents là dessus dans l'ambassade
américaine de téhéran
mais quelle époque israël et l'iran
étaient quasiment ailier tout à fait
c'étaient les principaux alliés
d'ailleurs puisque l'iran constitue
espèce de poids à la
à l'hostilité entre guillemets sunnite
qui était alors très homogène et
derrière les palestiniens est donc là
l'iran qu'on se faisait une sorte de
contrepoids une sorte de présence sur
les arrières sunnite
si je peut simplifier les choses cette
manière mais après dans les années des
années récentes surtout à partir des
années 2000 à partir du moment où les
américains sont entrés en irak
on a effectivement cette idée que les
iraniens veulent se doter de l'arme
pierre alors il est vrai que après l'aïd
ou au moment où les américains se
préparait à attaquer l'irak
les iraniens ont très bien compris
qu'ils pourraient être les suivants sur
la liste et donc qu'ils ont étudié la
faisabilité
je précise bien la faisabilité d'avoir
l'armé nucléaire comme arme de
dissuasion et donc il ya des études qui
ont été faites et qui ont abouti en 2003
par la conclusion que ça ne valait pas
la peine de se doter de l'armé nucléaire
et on sait et alors là je cite des
rapports de la cia qui est qui qui dit
très clairement que l'iran a décidé de
renoncer à l'armé nucléaire en 2003 et
là dessus s'est greffé le programme
civil qu'on a accusé de servir des
objectifs militaires
et puis on a en fait on a construit une
réalité un peu virtuel sur des
finalement l'idée que c' est qu' il y
avait cette ambition iranienne de se
doter de l'armé nucléaire
mais on n'a jamais trouvé tout ni l'âge
ans
pour la surveillance des d'énergie
atomique n'a découvert quoi que ce soit
on a même les documents que netanyahu
avait présenté en grande pompe en 2018
ont été finalement des documents qui
étaient qui avaient été rendues
publiques et qui avait déjà été livrés
aux inspecteurs de l'agencé des nations
unies
donc on a on a vraiment quelque chose
qui a été monté de toutes pièces on a
créé une menace régionale qui n'existent
pas les iraniens ont très bien compris
que ça ne servait à rien et que
probablement d'ailleurs lors leur
capacité de résister à l'intérieur du
pays d'oc la résistance j'allais dire
humaine suffirait à dissuader
ddd des étrangers ou des puissances
étrangères de s'attaquer à leur
territoire
donc on a vraiment créé le mythe
évidemment ils laissèrent les intérêts
des états unis qui peuvent de cette
manière maintenir une pression et
maintenir une présence au proche orient
et puis ça sert aussi naturellement la
politique israélienne et qui peut de
cette manière justifier ses actions
contre la syrie puisqu'elle voit la
syrie comme est un bastion avancé de la
d ambition militaire iranienne sur la
guerre rencontre contre le terrorisme
pour vous c'est quoi la la fausse vérité
qui est qui qui est sous jacente
mais en réalité le terrorisme comme je
les ai expliqué en introduction n'est
rien d'autre qu'une réaction à nos
interventions au moyen-orient c'est une
manière et c'est de nouveau c'est comme
je l'aï dit c'est quelque chose qui a
été expliqué en long large en travers et
qui écrit dans le détail
l'idée c'est d'ailleurs exactement le
même principe que ce qu'avait appliquer
les britanniques en bombardant
l'allemagne dans l'antre 1943 1945
il s'agissait de bombarder les civils
pour que les civils se retourne contre
les dirigeants nazis à l'époque
aujourd'hui les terroristes utilisent
exactement la même stratégie
ils sont aperçus à madrid en 2004 que là
les attentes ap avait eu comme
conséquence alors probablement ils ont
mal lu les événements mais malgré tout
ça a été leur conclusion que les
attentats de madrid avait eu comme
conséquence de provoquer le retrait
espagnol de l'irak
et c'est resté leurs modèles donc tous
les écrits que deux d'al qaïda mais
aussi de l'état islamique
on retrouve toujours ce modèle initial
et c'est ce modèle qui a été appliquée
par la suite en au royaume uni et en
france et qui s'appuie sur le fait que
les opinions publiques sont en fait sont
très opposés aux interventions
ça a été le cas au royaume uni avant
l'intervention en irak en 2003 et puis
c'était le cas avant les interventions
du gouvernement hollandais en irak et en
syrie en 2014 ou à peu près deux tiers
de la population française était opposé
à une intervention
les syndicats auraient ils sont très
bien vu ça donc ils ont décidé de
l'exploiter et et l'idée c'est que en
causant des en provoquant des morts sur
le territoire français
la population au tournerait contre le
gouvernement et réclamerait le retrait
ou la cessation des frappes en sièges et
en irak
ça c'est la stratégie problème c'est que
comme on aime pas avouer que le
terrorisme est la conséquence d'une
d'une stratégie finalement mal penser
stratégie occidentale mal pensée on
préfère prétendre qu'il ya un projet
global de d'occupation en fin de 2 de
conquête occident par
par l'islam où les islamistes
or la réalité montre d'abord que c'est
elles ont elles ont pris naissance en
fait aux états unis et puis d'autre part
on a le deuxième phénomène c'est quand
on n'a pas de structure en occident qui
permettent de prendre le relais des des
attentats terroristes
lorsqu'on avait par exemple les brigades
rouges des attentes le terrorisme
marxiste des années 70 80
on avait des terroristes qui faisait des
actions mais il y avait derrière la
préparation d'une structure qui puisse
prendre le relais politiques des du
succès du terrorisme si vous voulez pour
prendre le relais afin de d'aller au
delà des attentats terroristes et les
attentats de faux de transformer rien
ils ne permettent pas de conquérir le
pouvoir il faut quelque chose derrière
d'ailleurs quand on observe les volets
mouvement marxiste on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya toujours en volet politique et un
volet action en volet militaire
c'était la même chose pour l'été à
basques etc on n'a pas de la même chose
avec les djihadistes
ils sont pas du tout équipés préparer ou
structuré pour reprendre le pouvoir
d'ailleurs derrière
d'ailleurs on a très bien vu en france
ait eu des attentats terroristes
on sait qu'une grande partie de la
population émigrée et
disons je veux pas dire qu'ils sont pour
les théories ce serait faux de dire ça
mais ils comprennent
or quand on a eu les révoltes de bi
gilet jaune
on n'a pas vu de musulmans là dedans
c'est pas un combat qu'il dit qu'ils ont
repris ou qu'ils m'auraient et qu'ils
auraient pu exploiter en fait pour créer
une dynamique révolutionnaire voir ça
n'a pas du tout été le cas
on n'a absolument pas cette dynamique
révolutionnaire d'air qui vient en appui
ou dans la suite du terrorisme
terrorisme n'est pas une activité pour
soi c'est une activité qui s'inscrit
dans un processus en général
alors le processus islamistes c'est nous
nous pousser à nous retirer du
moyen-orient le processus marxiste et dé
prendre le pouvoir mais sont les
processus qui sont très claires et très
souvent quand on lit la presse on a
l'impression que les gens font des
attentats
simplement pour le plaisir de les faire
c'est tout non c'est pas du tout ça il
ya toujours un objectif d'air il ya
toujours un objectif d'air un attentat
jeannie mot sur la guerre en syrie ce
serait quoi alors la fausse vérité qu'on
a qu'on a installé à vos yeux
alors la fausse vérité c'est
naturellement qu'on a un gouvernement
qui était une dictature
et puis en appui de ça on a
naturellement l'idée que bachar el-assad
tente de massacrer son peuple alors là
aussi les faits tendent contredit à
contredire se fait d'abord quand on a
des soi-disant d information sur l usage
des structures d'armes de destruction
massive y compris les armes chimiques
contre la population
on s'aperçoit que comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure à propos des armes chimiques
on n'a pas de vrais faits c'est derrière
on a pas de faits avérés
on a des suppositions on a des
interprétations on a d'ailleurs éliminé
une bonne partie des éliminées des
informations qui
c'est car les nations unies avaient des
rapports selon lesquels et même les
services de renseignement américains
avaient des rapports selon lesquels le
diabate annoncera avait des armes
chimiques et créer des armes chimiques
déjà en 2010 donc avant même le début
des engagements par soi disant l'armée
syrienne donc on avait déjà beaucoup
d'informations avant sur ces choses
amères on les a soigneusement noté
d'ailleurs les notes officielles
publiées par le gouvernement
hollande pour justifier une éventuelle
intervention en syrie au mec tu des
faits qui sont pourtant dont les
dossiers des nations unies et que tous
les services de renseignement savaient
qu'ils étaient connus à l'époque mais on
a délibérément ignoré pour créer une
fausse réalité une fausse perception sur
la situation en syrie
alors il ya sans doute eu des massacres
en syrie et moi je ne le nie pas qu'il
ya eu des massacres
je ne lis pas qu'ils aient pas eu qu'il
n'y pas qu'ils aient eu d'aidé des
entorses même violente au droit
humanitaire international c'est certain
mais tout montre que les éléments qu'on
nous met sous le nez en occident pour
justifier des interventions sont faux on
a aussi l'exemple de ces fameuses
photographies de prisonniers qui
auraient été torturés et massacrés dans
les prisons des prisons syriennes
là aussi d'abord les organes des
organisations humanitaires qui ont
vérifié ces photos qui sont aperçus que
pratiquement toutes les photos en
question sont des photos de soldats
syriens et ils n'ont pas d'opposant déjà
quand même quelque chose qui cloche
ensuite à l'auteur de ces photos et bien
on ne le connaît
il a toujours pas été présenté au public
sous prétexte que le gouvernement syrien
qui l'avait pourtant mandaté pour faire
ces photos pour elle reconnaître et se
demande comment les gouvernements syrien
pour elle reconnaître dans l'année sur
dvd
comment des photos aujourd'hui alors que
si vraiment le gouvernement lui avait
donné la mission de recenser toutes les
tous les hommes torturés et massacrés
dans les prisons on peut s'imaginer
qu'ils n'ont pas donné cette mission
vingt mille personnes et qui a sans
doute qu'un ou deux candidats possibles
pour ceux ci donc en fait le gars qui en
est l'auteur devrait normalement savoir
qu'il est déjà connu il a pas besoin
jacques baud je vous interromps mais
vous êtes un homme du renseignement
quand vous voyez tout ça et que vous
l'analysez tels que vous l'analysez dans
ce livre et là vous êtes en train de
nous en donner quelques exemples parce
qu'il y en a énormément
est-ce que vous pensez que les pays
occidentaux vous parlez de gouvernement
de françois hollande par exemple penser
que françois hollande ment sciemment à
ce moment là ou bien il s'est laissé
auto ans et intoxiqué par des services
de renseignement étrangers comme ont
essayé le faire on le sait les
américains au moment de l'invasion de
l'irak ils ont essayé de d'intoxiquer un
certain nombre de pays alliés pour les
convaincre d accompagner où il s'est
peut-être laissé intoxiquer par ses
propres services de renseignements je ne
sais pas est ce qu'il ya une erreur
est ce qu'il ya une mauvaise
interprétation est ce qu'il ya un vrai
mensonge on se dit on veut aller
dégommer ce type là et on est prêt à
mentir pour y parvenir
et est-ce que ça a une influence sur la
résolution du conflit qui est
généralement à notre détriment
il faut bien regain si on prend la
sphère l'invasion de l'irak à la fin ça
débouche sur en gros l'iran et la russie
ont aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
d'influencé dans la région qui n'en
avaient avant l'invasion
donc c'est un échec total bon voilà je
vous ai fait toute la question
tout à fait d'accord c'est une
excellente question alors
d'abord il faut savoir qu'on ne sait pas
exactement sur quelle base les décideurs
prennent leurs décisions
il ya deux possibilités fondamentale la
première ce qui est services de
renseignements qui sont censés guider
leurs décisions sont mal informés ou en
font un mauvais travail d' analyse et
donc que les décideurs sont mal
renseignés ça c'est une des options
la deuxième option c'est ce que dit que
l'une pas où aller par exemple quand une
paul mendy c'est la cia qui m'a menti
sur les armes de destruction massive
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait le discours
qu'on me reproche l onu par exemple
alors ça on peut revenir parce qu'en
réalité on sait que la cia savait très
bien qu'il y avait pas d'armes de
destruction massive et d'ailleurs pour
prendre le cas de ce cas particulier
on sait que rome avait créé un service
de renseignement qui a d'ailleurs
disparu depuis un tout petit service d'
analyses directement subordonne à son à
son ministère pour établir en fait des
rapports de renseignement parce que
précisément la cia et les services de
renseignement militaires là des lilas
était savez qu'il ya queques y avait pas
de d'armes de destruction massive les
faisait des rapports qui ne plaisait pas
au secrétaire à la défense à l'époque et
qui plaisait pas au président donc on a
finalement on a on a créé une structure
pour faire de faux renseignements du
côté de manière cette structure à être
disparu depuis
mais elle a été conçue exclusivement
pour ça pour le cas de la de la france
ou de d'autres pays on ne sait pas
toujours comment ça se fait ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'en tout cas les notes de
renseignement qui ont été rendus publics
sont fausses
j'entends elles contiennent de
nombreuses erreurs factuelles et de
nombreuses omissions qui font qu'un on a
créé cette fausse perception de la
réalité
alors est ce que c'est
la version on a publié est ce que c'est
la version qui a été présentée au
président je ne sais pas la deuxième
deuxième aspect de la chose c'est le
décideur qui refusent d'écouter ce que
lui dit le renseignement c'est cool dans
ce cas de figure qu'on se situe à peu
près dans le cas de colin powell si vous
voulez quand vous voulez pas écouter
personne n'est plus sourd que celui qui
ne veut pas écouter et effectivement on
sait que dans bien des cas y compris
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui les le président
trump et et la cia
vous savez que la cia est une entité qui
est beaucoup plus démocrates entre
guillemets que républicaine et il ya
toujours eu en agonie sme entre la cia
et trump depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
et la cia a des avis qui sont
quelquefois très opposés au président
mais le président lui à j ai bien de
manière très indépendante en pouvoir en
raison de son pouvoir discrétionnaire et
c'est là qu'est un peu le problème notre
état de droit et il se trouve que je
suis expert des nations unies en état de
droit donc c'est ce fait c'est un peu un
sujet qui m'intéresse
l'état de droit un voeu que la décision
politique ou militaire ou stratégiques
comme vous voulez être une décision qui
est fondée sur des faits qui n'est pas
le simple fait du prince mais qui est
basée sur une réalité et c'est ce qui
fait la différence entre une
gouvernement de droit divin et puis des
gouvernements qui sont qui ont des
appareils
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on a des
services de renseignements c'est pour
objectiver d'une certaine manière la
décision politique
alors dans quelle mesure ça fonctionne
ou ça ne fonctionne pas dans les pays
ça on ne sait pas il est très
vraisemblable que dans beaucoup de cas
on prenne des décisions n'ont pas
nécessairement pour intervenir en syrie
ont enfin ou plus exactement on
intervient en syrie en libye
non pas parce qu'on en veut
au président en exercice mais simplement
pour des raisons quelquefois de
politique intérieure on a reproché c'est
d'ailleurs l'analyse des services de
renseignements britanniques après
l'intervention en libye il ya une
analyse qui était faite par la
commission des services de
renseignements du parlement britannique
qui dit qu'en réalité la france s'est
engagée en libye pour remonter un petit
peu la cote de popularité de sarkozy
en prévision de la présidentielle de
alors ça c'est l'analyse des services
britanniques ce n'est pas la mienne
quoique je pense qu'ils ont ils ont
raison et d'ailleurs beaucoup de
commentateurs notamment américains ont
eu à l'époque la même idée donc il
devrait semblables qui est un aspect
politiciens à 7 à ces décisions qui ait
pas de décisions rationnelles et
qu'ensuite après fou on y applique une
rationalité ou fabriquent une
rationalité pour expliquer une décision
qui était mauvaise dès le départ qu'ils
consomment en ce qui concerne la libye
on est dit aussi que c'est parce que la
france avait peut-être pas été à la
hauteur des révolutions arabes et
notamment tunisie qui fallait redorer
son blason non pas seulement du fait de
l'électorat français en vue de 2012 mais
surtout de des populations arabes et ça
expliquerait et la libye et la façon
aussi dont la france voulait absolument
intervenir en syrie contre bachar
el-assad de la même manière à tous à
tout à fait absolument je pense que
d'ailleurs les cette explication n'est
pas du tout exclusive par rapport à aux
autres elles se complètent et et se se
complémentent sans problème au lieu ceux
qui ne se sentent pas ce qu'il nous
reste très peu de temps
jacques baud est-ce que c'est est ce que
ce serait l'explication pour vous
pourquoi l'occident depuis assez
longtemps père les guerres c'est à dire
qu'on intervient on interdit en irak on
intervient en libye
on veut intervenir en syrie on
intervient contre des shu on intervient
au mali on intervient partout on ne
gagne jamais c'est quand même ça le
résultat on s'enlise on reste là
ne gagne jamais ni en afghanistan ni
ailleurs est ce que c'est parce que au
départ on y est allé pour de mauvaises
raisons en tout cas affiché sur de
mauvais renseignements
ce serait l'explication alors c'est une
partie de l'explication
l'autre partie de l'explication c'est
qu'on se bat contre des adversaires
qu'on ne connaît pas et qu'on refuse de
connaître et que souvent on juge d'après
précisément des fausses vérités
c'est à dire qu en fonction en fonction
de nos préjugés en fonction de nos
perceptions et non pas en fonction de ce
qu'ils sont moi comme agent de
renseignement mon travail c'était de
comprendre la manière dont les
soviétiques ou le pacte de varsovie à
l'époque pensait et c'est cet effort
intellectuel qu'il faut faire si on veut
se battre contre un adversaire si on
oublie la réalité de l'adversaire si on
oublie ce qu'il est si on oublie comme
on y pense
comment ils comment il réagit quelle est
sa logique
quelle est sa logique d'action quelle
est sa stratégie eh bien on est sûr de
perdre on est en fait dans quelque chose
que son souhait avait déjà décrit
exactement comme ça il y à plus de 2000
euros donc on est exactement là dedans
on n'a pas du tout compris comment
fonctionne l italie beau tout simplement
on n'a pas du tout fonctionné et comment
fonctionne l on a cru que les américains
ont cru qu en allant en irak qu'ils
allaient être accueillis comme des
libérateurs un peu comme leclerc
arrivant à paris en 44 or ça n'a pas du
tout été ça et il ya une très petite
partie de la population qui l'a
accueilli mais le reste a senti qu'on
l'était dessous une nouvelle occupation
et ça à déclencher une autre guerre
c'était le même phénomène en libye où on
a cru qu'on lit on en fait on a libéré
les faux les faux acteurs quand on
entend les discours de bernard henri
lévy à benghazi etc
on se dit ils se trouvent complètement
d'auditoire et en fait son auditoire
sans qu'ils s'en aperçoivent ou sans
qu'il le réalise ou sans qu'ils
veuillent le réaliser étaient en fait
des islamistes convaincu et c'est
exactement ces gens là
qui aujourd'hui sont combattus
d'ailleurs par la france merci jacques
baud gouverné par les faits que news
votre livre est paru chez max milo merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]